January 6 2021 when we saw those large
groups of people amass on the Capitol
Hill you will remember this man's face
particularly his name is Jacob chancelly
he is the so-called Q Anon Shaman and
for his role on that day he was
sentenced to 41 months in prison he's
since been released early joins us now
to give us his unique perspective on the
man many say inspired his actions Donald
Trump Jacob thanks for making time for
us uh I know it's a strangely a busy
time for you to be talking about this
um but first of all um let's just remind
our viewers because we were very
International audience here you were the
face of this January 6 Uprising you were
the guy in the fur coat and the horns
and everything else you were the
so-called shame and how do you feel
about all that now
well it's clear that the operation
Mockingbird media chose to make me their
straw man they chose to use my face and
my image to create a shock and awe
campaign that they then used to divide
the country into people that support
Donald Trump and people that don't and
anybody that uh sees that what was done
to me and doesn't agree with it they now
are beginning to see how it is that the
American justice system is corrupt and
has been corrupt for decades when you
were sentenced you you were very
remorseful you said quote I was wrong
for entering the capital I have no
excuse whatsoever in retrospect I'd do
everything differently I would try with
all my heart and soul to stop people
that also joined you that day do you
feel still feel the same
well if I wouldn't know what was going
to happen I definitely would have tried
to stop everything from happening before
it happened and you know what I did was
technically illegal so of course you
know there's no defense for an illegal
action
um but I have you know accepted
responsibility I have served my time and
because of my good behavior in prison as
well as my programming while I was in
prison the the the programming that I
did in the prison I got a year off my
sentence and was released early so I
think that's indicative of the fact that
what it is that the operation
Mockingbird media said about me is just
completely unfounded gewclass this is
Operation Mockingbird media
well yeah absolutely but you know the
thing is is Operation Mockingbird has
been going on for a very long time it's
when the CIA infiltrated the media
Outlets during the Civil Rights movement
during the anti-war movement in the 60s
and the 70s and they were hell-bent on
controlling the narrative in the country
because it's all about controlling the
minds of the people controlling the
minds of the public through
psychological warfare techniques
combining trigger words with trigger
images to create an emotional response
in the subconscious mind that can then
be weaponized against groups of
individuals or individuals like Donald
Trump or myself now I'm uh listening to
all that and then you say it because
it's uh your First Amendment right to
add that point of view I'm of course a
journalist I work here I can tell you I
was never recruited by the CIA
um but it is always interesting to hear
this because it is the Q Anon movement
this conspiracy movement some call it
some call it a cult it captured the
minds of so many people are you still in
the movement it sounds like your views
haven't changed do you think they've got
stronger
well Q Anon is a fiction created by the
media so they could discredit q and the
anons that were following q and on is a
fiction created by the media so that
they could basically smear the very
founded realizations and Revelations of
a debt-based fiat currency controlling
our monetary system the child in human
trafficking networks that are all over
the planet and are used by these Elite
groups that control the banks and the
Federal Reserve to Blackmail people into
submission like what was happening with
Jeffrey Epstein if you look into what
happened with Jeffrey Epstein and the
fact that his Client List has not been
made public or the fact that uh like the
finders which is on the government
website and how children were being
abducted and and abused and put in cages
if you look into
um the testimony of Ronald Bernard if
you look into Franklin cover up in
Nebraska Jay could we could keep
listening all night yeah we could keep
going online
here in the United Kingdom
do it yourself yeah you're a journalist
you'll look into it yourself these
things are very real you can look them
up very easily and if you're a
journalist and you really want to you
really care about your country whether
it be in the UK or in the United States
then you'll look into these things and
realize that to quote to quote Kennedy
let me just quote Kennedy really quick
we are opposed around the world by a
monolithic and ruthless conspiracy that
relies primarily on Covert means for
expanding its sphere of influence on
infiltration instead of invasions on
subversions instead of Elections on
intimidation instead of free choice on
gorillas by night instead of arms
go and you can have two you can have
five more seconds finish your point okay
is a system that's just conspired vast
human and material resources to create a
tightly knit highly efficient machine
that combines military diplomatic
scientific economic and political
operations okay these preparations all
different viewpoints and opinions much
like the first amendment there in the
U.S so we are going to open it up now to
our panel who joined me in the studio
who were listening to all of that and
ask you what you make of it all when
that is somebody who claims to be one of
Trump's major supporters Paula I have to
say that what I would like to ask Jacob
is I'm intrigued about the whole
corruption I'm intrigued about the
political power and yet he doesn't seem
to be uncomfortable with the fact that
every time Trump sends out a press
release there's a fundraising link
attached to it I mean why is nobody
uncomfortable about that normal part of
American politics
why is nobody uncomfortable about that
was my question why is it the case that
we are quite happy to attach
fundraising to what should be something
politics is that so well it's so amazing
imagine that state funded it's
uncomfortable for me that a man who ran
a number of businesses into the ground
could then take over a country and is
now suggesting that this country is
somehow corrupt is that it is just the
American system it might feel
uncomfortable for us but they are
allowed you know private businesses
private donors private everything to
fund themselves to the moon and they do
need but it's literally that is
literally what happens in the UK I send
out
regulated yeah I sent out an email every
other week asking for donations I've got
my own business I'm running a political
party we're seeking votes we would like
to help run this country better so
that's it's what you've just said is
there's nothing corrupt about that
process our donations are clearly
declared above a certain level I would
suggest that there are questions that
Jacob may have wanted to ask Trump about
that and maybe wanted to stress about
that but he seems quite comfortable to
to allow Trump to behave in ways that
may be questionable I have said that as
as a man who has run a number of
businesses those businesses and the way
he has run them has been questionable
um and he has faced a number of very
serious questions about that he doesn't
seem to be worried about that and that
he's taken that questionable Behavior
into his presidency he doesn't seem
uncomfortable about that